if you're healthy enough
for sexual activity.
If you have an erection
lasting longer than four hours,
call me!
Hi, I'm Amy Schumer,
and you can buy lab coats
on eBay.
An erection that won't go away
is considered
a medical emergency,
but in my book, it's more
of a medical opportunity.
Here in my state-of-the-art
facility,
you and I will handle
the situation together.
How much does it cost?
Free.
No insurance?
Me neither.
Never have.
Probably never will.
Medically-induced erections are
nothing to be ashamed of.
You should be proud
and more importantly,
you should be on your way
over here.
If I can't wrestle
that gator down,
no doctor will be able to.
So please,
for your health,
call the emergency number
on your screen right now.
It's my number.
(phone ringing)
Oh.
Hi, this is Amy.
Yes, I'm avail--
Oh, it already went down?
Just from hearing my voice?
You sure?
Well, thank you for cal--
Hello?
Okay, that was a wrong number.
You can call me literally
any time, 24 hours,
seven days a week.
I'm available at midnight
on New Year's,
for the last three years.